it's more than two weeks since the first
reports of around 200 chinese vessels
anchored at whitson reef in the south
china sea
many are still there china says there
are fishing boats
sheltering from stormy seas the
philippine government believes
they are manned by a chinese militia and
it wants them to leave
saying the area is within the
philippines economic zone
defense secretary delfin lorenzana
believes china is attempting to occupy
more of the disputed waterway
a charge beijing denies
the philippine side should view this
issue objectively and correctly
immediately stop unwarranted hype up and
avoid negative impacts on bilateral
relations
and overall peace and stability of the
south china sea
beijing continues to assert it owns most
of the south china sea
despite that claim being rejected by an
international tribunal at the hague in
2016.
in manila there is growing anger against
the chinese embassy
after it issued a statement criticizing
the philippines defense secretary's
comments
as unprofessional and perplexing there
have been calls for the chinese
ambassador to be expelled
with embassy officials warned they were
in the country
as guests of the philippine government
the philippine foreign affairs office
said
it will launch diplomatic protests about
the whitson reef occupation
unprecedented so why why the gal to
speak against a member of our cabinet
who is simply defending national
interests
standing up for the territorial
integrity of the philippines
based on international law across asia
other countries are also protesting
china's military expansions
china held naval drills involving an
aircraft carrier battle group near
taiwan
while japan criticized what it called
chinese coast guard's aggressive
behavior
around the senkaku islands meanwhile the
u.s navy carrier theodore roosevelt
and its strike group re-entered the
south china sea over the weekend
its second appearance this year
china says this is highly provocative
but the u.s navy says
it has a right to operate in the south
china sea
underlining the importance of freedom of
navigation
in international waters in the
philippines though much of the blame is
still directed
towards the government people here say
the territories under the control of the
philippines in the south china sea
have never been more threatened and that
president rodrigo duterte's so-called
pivot to china
in 2016 is turning out to be
a capitulation jamella allendogen
al jazeera manila